- [Instructor] We're
now going to talk about
the main division that emerges in Islam
shortly after the death of Muhammad.
And that division is
between Sunnis and Shias.
And this division even exists today
where roughly 90% of the world's 1.5
or 1.6 billion Muslims are Sunni,
and roughly 10% are Shia.
And that 10% is concentrated mainly
in places like Iran,
Iraq, but they are spread
throughout the Muslim world
or the world in general.
Now, the word Sunni comes
from the word Sunnah
which is referring to
examples of Muhammad.
The word Shia comes from shi'atu 'Ali
which means followers
of Ali or party of Ali,
and we'll talk more about
Ali in a little bit.
But, the general division is over
who should succeed
Muhammad after his death
as the leader of the Muslim community.
Shias believe it should be
members of Muhammad's family
and especially descendants of Muhammad,
while the Sunnis believe
that it doesn't necessarily
have to be that.
But, as we'll see, this division becomes
stronger and stronger and stronger
as there's more and more bloodshed
between the two parties.
Because so much of this revolves around
the family of Muhammad,
let's just review that first
and then we'll talk about the division
over who should succeed
Muhammad as caliph or successor
to lead the Muslim community.
So, you see Muhammad
right over here born 570.
We have his birth on our timeline as well.
And just to read this timeline,
it goes from light blue to dark blue
when Muhammad, according
to Islamic tradition,
starts to have the revelations from God.
And the Muslim calendar starts at 622,
the time of the Hijrah
where the Muslim community,
in order to escape
persecution from the Quraysh,
migrate from Mecca to Medina.
Now, we've talked about
several of these figures
in other videos.
Right over here, you have
Muhammad's dad, Adbullah,
who dies several months
before Muhammad is born.
You have Aminah here who
is Muhammad's mother,
and she dies when
Muhammad is six years old.
Then, you have Abdul-Muttalib
who is the head
of Muhammad's, you could say, household
and he takes custody
after the death of Aminah.
And he takes custody until
Muhammad is eight years old
when Abdul-Muttalib dies,
and then Muhammad's uncle,
Abu Talib, takes custody.
It's under Abu Talib that
Muhammad learns his trade
as a merchant and as a trader.
Now, later on, we talk about Khadijah
who is a wealthy widow in Mecca,
and she employs Muhammad and
according to Islamic tradition,
is impressed by him and proposes to him,
and she's 15 years older than Muhammad.
This is her third marriage,
and Muhammad marries her.
She's a significant figure in Islam,
not because she is Muhammad's first wife,
but also because she is the first Muslim.
Now, as you can see,
Muhammad and Khadijah,
they have several children,
and I list one of them here, Fatimah,
because Fatimah ends up
marrying Abu Talib's son, Ali.
And Ali is the Ali that
we're talking about
where the word Shia, shi'atu
'Ali comes from, party of Ali.
Because Ali is considered
the second Muslim.
He is one of the early
followers of Muhammad.
As you can see, he is Muhammad's cousin.
He grows up in the same
household with Muhammad
with Abu Talib, and he is
also Muhammad's son-in-law.
He marries Fatimah and
they have several children,
two of which are Hassan and Hussein
who figure very prominently
in the narrative
I'm going to talk about in
this video and the next.
Now, the other figures that you see here,
you have Abu Bakr who
was a close companion
of Muhammad, also one
of the early Muslims.
And you can see he was a little
bit younger than Muhammad.
And they are connected through Aisha.
Muhammad marries Aisha
after the death of Khadijah,
and Aisha is a significant
figure in early Islam.
She's considered to have
a very strong personality.
Many of the Hadith are narrated by her.
The Hadith are the Muslim
traditions and accounts
of Muhammad's life, and
it's a significant part
of the religion outside of the Quran.
And she is married to Muhammad
at a very, very young age,
and there's some debate about
how young she actually was.
But, as we'll see, she
also figures prominently
in this narrative and in
this schism that develops
between the Sunni and the Shia.
And the Sunni and the
Shia view her differently.
So, let's go back to the timeline here.
So, as Muhammad's life
nears its end in 632,
in previous videos, we talk about
his final pilgrimage to Mecca.
And then, on his way back to Medina,
at a place like Ghadir
Khumm, he gives a sermon,
a sermon that is especially
very important to the Shia.
According to that short sermon.
And Ghadir Khumm, Ghadir
literally means pond
or small stream, so it's the
sermon at the pond Khumm.
There's one quotation that Shia consider
to be very, very important
where Muhammad says
"Of whomsoever I had been Mawla."
Ali here is to be his Mawla.
And the word Mawla means
protector or leader,
or it could mean guardian or
people that you are close to.
And the Shia view this as clear evidence
that Muhammad intended
Ali to be his successor.
Many members of the Sunni tradition
take a slightly different interpretation
where they say Mawla
doesn't necessarily have
to mean protector or leader.
It could mean companion or friend
or member that is close to,
and so they don't view this
as strongly of evidence.
But, in the Shia tradition,
the event at Ghadir Khumm
is actually a significant
event and it is even a holiday.
So, that's the evidence that Shia point to
as why Ali should be the successor.
But, then Muhammad dies, and
according to the tradition,
while his funeral was being
planned by his family,
the close companions were meeting
and discussing who
should succeed Muhammad.
And the close companions decide
that is should be Abu Bakr.
So, Abu Bakr becomes the first caliph,
and he rules for two years.
He's succeeded by Umar,
sometimes pronounced as Omar,
who then is assassinated
who is succeeded by Uthman,
sometimes pronounced as Osman
who is then assassinated.
And then, Ali takes power.
According to Sunni tradition,
these first four caliphs
are considered the Rashidun caliphs
or the rightly guided.
And under their rule, you
have the significant spread
of what becomes this Islamic empire
that we talk about in other videos.
In Shia tradition, they consider
these first three caliphs as usurpers.
They believe that Ali
should have been caliph
from the beginning right in 632
at the time of Muhammad's death.
And once again, they cite
the events at Ghadir Khumm
which was observed according to the Hadith
by thousands of people
and there's many, many accounts of this.
Now, Ali is in power, but as we will see
in the next video, this
starts the first civil war,
the first Muslim civil war, often referred
to as the First Fitna, between Ali
and the Umayyad's who
are the family of Uthman,
and we will cover that in the next video.